I'm Angela McCaffery.
And I'm Patrick Clark.
Well, and you're supposed to be Angela Clark.
Yes.
Changing the name soon.
Another thing we have not gotten around to.
We have been together for eight years and married one.
This is Tommy.
We haven't been outside in like, two years.
Yeah.
Patrick works in the basement like a garden gnome and-
A troll of sorts.
With no windows.
And I own two businesses that I'm trying desperately
to keep afloat in the middle of a pandemic,
with this baby.
So, we have let go of ourselves
and we look crazy
(chuckling softly)
and we need your help.
And we're so grateful to be considered.
We hope to see you soon.
Make us over!
(audience applauding)
So obviously, we're here with Drew Crew member
extraordinaire, Zanna Roberts Rassi to help.
Zanna, what are some tips
to keep ourselves falling into that rut?
It's so easy to fall into a style rut
and there's a few really practical tips I like to use.
Number one, pick a style muse.
It could be someone off social media,
it could be a celebrity.
Literally analyze what they wear.
Think about the color, the silhouette, the shape
and copy it.
It's that simple.
Just buy the look.
There're always affordable versions.
And another great tip is actually,
and you have to be a little bit brave for this,
but find your best dressed friend or someone in the family
who's got good style and say, "Make me over".
Just do it.
You will be surprised, they will come up with ideas
that you would never in million of years have tried
on your own.
All right.
Well, I'm so excited to see what you've done.
Is everybody ready for the big reveal?
First we have Patrick.
(audience applauding)
And here is what Patrick looked like before.
I think Patrick looks great,
but I'm excited to see how Patrick looks now.
(audience applauding)
(Patrick laughs)
(audience cheering)
Nice job.
Oh my God!
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
Sharp, no?
Okay, I'm just gonna be super honest with you
and I hope that your wife feels the exact same way.
I thought, you know what?
You look fine, you don't need do anything,
when I saw your picture.
Yeah.
You come out and you look so attractive
and I think your wife
(audience applauding)
is gonna be so pleased!
Zanna, what did you do?
You just nailed it.
It's literally that.
It's like fashion and function together.
It's these utility pieces.
Clean black, super flattering.
I love the idea.
It feels a little bit street wear.
A nice knit underneath, as well.
No scrappy T-shirts, no dodgy neck lines.
You want something
that looks a little bit more elevated underneath,
since this is a nice knit.
Clean black pant, can't go wrong with that.
And a white sneaker.
And if you're gonna wear a white sneaker, boys
make sure it's clean and crisp and looks like, freshy.
Okay.
How do you feel, Partick?
'Cause that's always my biggest question.
How do you feel?
I feel amazing.
I feel hip, I feel cool.
You do?
There. That's it, right?
(audience applauding)
Yeah, I was like...
Thank you.
I feel, it's like a new lease on life.
I feel like you really need to make sure
that you look and feel good
even when you're working from 'cause-
Agreed.
Yeah, 'cause you do get in this rut and I think
if you dress a little bit more from on the outside,
then you're gonna feel
a little bit more confident on the inside.
You're gonna have a bit more motivation to go do stuff,
right?
(audience applauding)
Yeah, exactly.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
Are you excited for your wife to see you?
Yeah, I'm a little freaked out.
'Cause I'm amazed at what they've done with me,
I can't wait to see what they've done with her.
Oh, just you wait my friend.
Just you wait.
Well, okay.
We haven't seen Angela yet,
but here is what she looked like before.
Is it true Patrick,
that your wife hasn't cut her hair in 20 years?
Yeah.
Yeah, 20 years.
Well, I can't think of a bigger gift to new parents
than a new little lease on life when it comes to each other.
Angela, come on out.
(audience applauding)
Wow. Wow.
Hi, babe.
(audience applauding)
You look amazing.
Thank you.
I'm actually gonna cry, so lets not-
Wow!
Angela, you look so beautiful.
Thank you.
First of all,
I cannot stop staring at your lips.
I know.
Thank you. Thank you.
And your hair is phenomenal.
I mean, we should have taken a picture
of the amount of hair that was on the floor after this hack.
It's like, two feet of hair on the floor.
It's like version of me,
which is really exciting.
And how much easier,
as well to manage, you know.
You've got-
Am I allowed to kiss you?
Oh, look.
Oh, yes you are!
You look so handsome too.
Thank you.
I know, by the way.
Yeah. It's amazing.
It's like, I feel like we're,
it sounds cheesy, but young again.
Yeah.
Like, you really get lost
in the like, how much milk did I pump?
Did you change his diaper?
Like, you know, all that.
And now I'm like, this is how we were when we met.
Absolutely.
Well, I'm gonna cry, so.
(chuckles)
No!
Well, now you have got the fabulous outfits.
Thanks to you, thank you.
So, where are you gonna take it out for a spin first?
That's a real, well-
You tell me.
Yeah?
(Angela laughs)
I think probably a Steakhouse, but you-
Whoo, all right.
(audience applauding)
Let's hold him to it.
I'd be happy with a Deli, but a Steakhouse works too.
You've dressed the part for the date,
now let's get you on one.
Thank you so much.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
Thank you, Angela and Patrick.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much, Zanna.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)